well i should
probably say up front that i am a big
fan of the purge franchise and
oh thank you in all the films and every
episode of the tv shows
oh really oh that's cool see that's
that's rare i like that
i very much appreciate how it's
continued to evolve because
oh thank you have very much taken the
safe route and it hasn't
oh thank you thank you it means a lot
seriously i'm curious when you
wrote and directed the original film did
you have
a bigger vision for a franchise that it
could eventually evolve into
or did you see it as one film
two things i think i i didn't have a
vision i'm not gonna lie i had uh
i really thought it was originally
conceived
as i really thought it would be this
tiny little india i'd chew for a million
bucks it would show at the angelica and
now
in new york and just this tiny indy that
didn't really have much commercial value
at all because i thought it was
as people were telling us about the
script they just thought it was
incredibly dark and demented and twisted
and anti-american
and all that stuff so i didn't have much
beyond that i'm like i'll do this one
it'll be a one-off and i'll move on
hopefully to something else if i'm lucky
enough to make another film and
then jason saw a bigger potential than i
saw
and then i think well here's what here's
what did happen though while i was
shooting one
i realized i had a weird i i started to
feel like wow the conceit of the movie
is large right we're saying
the streets of america are running crazy
with violence
running rampant with all this vibe this
legalized violence i'm like i think
there's going to be a portion of the
audience understandably
that's going to be somewhat upset that
we're confined to a house
so i used to joke on set saying hey if
we're a hit and we get to do part two
which i thought was the most outlandish
thing in the world to say
i go i'm gonna do we're gonna go on the
streets of new york and show purging
outside
so that was the conceit that part two
would be much bigger which is not really
a vision of anything but
no to be quite honest we really thought
it would be one and out
when did you realize then that that that
potential was there that
that you were gonna have to go back and
and figure out what to do next
do not until christina honestly wasn't
until that friday of opening even the
week of opening i remember
talking to my agent saying so what's a
decent opening like where do i not feel
like a failure in the eyes of hollywood
and i could make another film right they
were just looking very practically at
the
and he's like oh if you do 10 or 11
that's a good opening i'm like oh okay
so we're looking at 10 or 11 and then we
look the movie looks like it was our
cheap film
and then we opened to that crazy weekend
where we did like 17 on the friday and
we ended up making like i think 38
million that was crazy opening and uh
we realized at that point that everybody
was calling and saying you need to start
thinking of the future
of the franchise and it was a word i
never even heard you know never thought
of before
and um yeah so that was at that point i
started saying okay
let me start thinking of the bigger
themes here that i'm dealing with racial
discord racial inequality
you know horror obviously horror and
action and how do we open this up and
i went back to all the movies i loved as
a kid escape from new york the warriors
were great influences on me so we
started thinking of
getting into those you know what i think
of the greatest b-movies ever made all
that that inspired me to make the rest
of the series at that point
after doing anarchy and election year
what made you then decide to start
handing them off you know handing off
first purge and now forever purge to
other filmmakers to direct it was i
think it was a combination of
after the first three happened so fast i
was kind of burned out and i did think i
did think initially the third one might
be the last one
stupidly i know i was being very naive
just do it
like if things make money i know people
want more of them but i was just
thinking like i'm creatively finished
i've told my trilogy
and and i also had written another
script that i really wanted to make
in between the purges and um and that
one had
around that time jason said he could get
the money for the other script i had
written
and i was so focused on that but then i
had written
purge four they asked for and i came up
with an idea for purge four which was
the inception of the purge and my
hometown of staten island and all that
stuff so
it was more practical i was like and
then i also started thinking
it would be really great to to bring in
filmmakers who could bring
a new perspective into this world yes
i'll write them but then we'll get
someone else to come in here who can
start
you know adding something new to the my
voice alone i thought maybe
not that not that it was becoming stale
i hope it wasn't becoming sale but it
would be nice to get some no viewpoints
into the and that's why gerrard came in
at that point
how do you feel about the tv shows
placement then within the franchise
would you have wanted to continue
doing that or do you feel that you've
accomplished what you hoped to
no i wish listen between you and i i
wish the tv show went on i had a i had
an idea for
purge purge season three that i was very
excited by um
you know i kind of oversaw the shows i
know i wasn't show running but we had
great showrunners both years so
and i was very close working closely
with them so we had more places we did
want to explore
um and we were thinking of even going
overseas for one of the purge seasons
and like with the
the conceit being that you know parts of
american culture
american society obviously go they go
abroad what happens if the purge started
to spread around the world the way
music does or movies so we wanted to
really continue it
usa unfortunately for various reasons
politically just didn't see the
i don't know if they're even making any
original affair anymore i heard they're
not but
now um yeah it was just so maybe
there'll be a permutation in the future
to continue
what i liked about the tv was the real
estate of having 10 hours
to explore the purge concede you're one
of the people who saw it it was a way to
do things like
you know like season two was between
purges we could never do that in the
movie ever
so that was kind of fun to go into that
stuff we could never do in a film
yeah i mean that's what i really liked
about it i felt really interesting
when when you wrote the forever purge
did you
approach it as the final installment in
the franchise
is that how you thought of it is that
how you still think of it
i did completely up until four months
ago no i
it was the complete it was the complete
final stage it was it it was
as you saw you saw the movie as you saw
how it ended like that with america on
fire and
that was like kind of my this is it me
and everybody like this is how we're
ending it and
and then i woke up four months ago and i
had a new i'm like oh god i was kind of
almost sad i'm not sad i was like oh
[ __ ] i have a new idea
and um i pitched it to everybody and
they really liked it so i think
if the if the audience wants it and the
cinema gods
tell us we can do it i think we have
another one that we we'd be excited to
do
is that also i mean is that the one that
you would talk to possibly you know
bringing frank grillo back
yes how'd you know i i talked to frank
about i know
i'm not on social media but i got calls
from people saying frank is talking
about a purge sick said he's going to be
and i'm like that son of a [ __ ] i told
him secretly
yeah i think he's just always excited
and i know he's so excited so cute i
love that character and i know that i'm
sure a lot of other people do as well oh
i love them too i got it right and i was
the first thought i'm like oh my god
this is the perfect way to bring it back
it's such a i think a fun way the
audience i would love it and
and if he's in it maybe i would love to
direct it with him so it would be really
fun
i think that the setup for this film is
so relevant
and the role that mexico plays in this
story is really
quite brilliant what were the initial
ideas that you wanted to explore in this
did that
and did that evolve and change at all as
you worked on it
yeah a little bit you know it was weird
i think that the strangest part of all
this is i started and everybody got very
scared when i said this i
initially called everybody and said i'm
gonna do a love story in purge five and
they're like what
what are you saying you added you gone
mad i'm like no no i want to do this
couple
this just so into so in love and they're
coming up from mexico together and
they're
getting away from the cartel violence
and they're seeking the american dream
and it's a it's an exploration of is the
american dream still alive is it dead
and everybody thought i was
like what are you even this is like what
are you making an independent film what
are you talking about
and but i think what was going on in the
border i did the border crisis was
really informing a lot of what i was
thinking about and
and i always wanted to move about a
couple one of the first films about this
intense you know passionate couple
so that was always the initial idea and
then i couple that with the idea that
i knew i had to flip purging on its head
i had to come up with a new way that
i think 12 doing another 12 hour window
i think would have been boring to do
like we got to flip it up and hit it on
its head and do something different
and then and i also wanted to do
something in a different color palette
something outside of a city all these
things were coming together and then the
idea of the forever purge kind of just
hit me one day like oh people just why
would they stop it's almost like an
infection that they can't contain
it's it's like i always said it was like
a zombie film perch five like it's just
this uncontainable
force in a weird way it's almost like a
faceless entity is
like running rampant in america um so
yeah it evolved but it never
those were all the initial thoughts and
then everato obviously came in the
beautiful influence of evorado was just
calling me out on my [ __ ] saying you
know the mexicans don't speak like this
jd
like let's get this right like and he
brought that to the table which was
wonderful
and i love the cast too that he brought
into this oh my god
right and that was all him that was
literally first meeting he said those
two names i'm like okay i know anna i
didn't know tanosh i knew a little bit
of narcos
but we watched his work and then we
showed it to peter at the studio and
everybody was on board
that's wonderful actors you can't deny
it so it also seems like
you know horror in the daytime just
wouldn't be scary but somehow it's still
terrifying it is right isn't that weird
that's what i said i was like and the
way they lit it
i mean i knew we had to do dates i'm
like we have to get out of the night and
that's what the forever purge allowed us
but
the way luis and everado lit it it's
like this hazy brightness it's so creepy
to me
with the masks and the sun i love it
it's fun
i know that you had also reunited with
frank grillo for once upon a time in
staten island
yes are we going to get to see that
yeah hopefully listen i'm hoping i just
got word maybe in
like three months from now two months
from now it'll have some kind of release
i don't know the exact i can't speak to
exactly but i got
good news that this it's out it's going
to come out i'm really proud of it i
think it's such a departure for me
from the purge world it's uh it's about
my love of cinema
and uh we changed the title though now
it's cool we didn't want to compete with
quentin's film so it's going to be this
is the night
it's about my love of cinema it's about
may 28 1982 the night rocky iii opens in
theaters around the country and how it
inspires the italian americans of staten
island to
do things they've never done before
courageously we follow one family on
that night frank plays the
dad in that family and he's he's he has
a scene at the end of the movie that i
can't wait for people to see it's the
best acting i've ever seen to do
do you know what's next for you as a
filmmaker i mean are you someone who is
always writing and developing things how
do you approach
working on stuff yeah so i wrote
something over the with a buddy of mine
uh
a guy from the neighborhood we wrote
something together like literally we
were both uh we
he was his family was in my bubble we
were in the same bubble so we saw each
other he was the only person i saw
other than my wife and daughter and we'd
sit in my backyard and we started
riffing on ideas he's a movie fanatic
and we came up with an idea i'm like
that's good so we wrote it together over
the break and we gave it to sebastian
and jason and jason
just screamed at the film and we're
trying to uh cast it now
and we're trying to get a friend of mine
who lives up the street in staten island
pete davidson from king of staten island
but in a serious role not a funny role
and uh
it's it's a psychological horror and um
we're hoping maybe this year in october
so that's what fingers crossed that
would be the next thing up
that would be cool and then maybe if
people want it purge six would be
probably the end of next year or
something like that if we did it
uh but you never know anything can
happen with the purge so you never know
i love how you say if people want it
people wanna i know
many people go back i gotta pray people
go back to i'm so nervous about i'm a
theater fanatic i love that's what my
whole movie this is night is about is
about the sanctity of the theater going
experience i'm so worried that
i just need people to go back you know
scary
anyway do you have a favorite film
in the the purge series or is that too
hard to
no i actually do i think i like oh i
know i shouldn't say oh my god no no i
would be i would get maybe mad i do
though
[Laughter]
i really like [ __ ] i was gonna give my
top two i'll give
so i don't get anyone angry i'll give
one of my top two five is in my top two
i won't give the other one because i'll
get i know i'll get someone mad so i'm
leading someone out
and two of the men in the series are
very competitive with each other but i
won't say who
well do you have a favorite purge look
in this film i mean i love that we get
purge bunnies purge cowboys even purge
construction workers yeah we got perch
construction workers that cracked me up
um my favorite purge look i think
it's weird because this is the first one
i didn't i usually design all the masks
in the film so i didn't design them this
time this was we
we gave it i was off shooting so um
i really like the bunnies the bunnies
came great even that contraption i wrote
that contraption but they did it better
than i wrote it it's so cool
yeah i love how striking the looks are
in this one it's not just
the mask it's like it's the whole thing
right it's like a whole outfit this time
yeah they they want one even the bunny
outfits a full body outfit yeah
it's not just this anymore which is kind
of cool yeah i love that
it is creepy because it's you know it's
you know what you'll see on halloween
now
exactly no it's true in the neighborhood
i live in it's so funny because people
knock on my door all the kids dress up
as purge characters so
we always have every year all the kids
dressed up and like i think this is a
good thing
sometimes it worries me i i love to the
whole
kind of last stand sequence when they're
having to like
run that gauntlet of a tank and
explosions and all the shooting
how much of that gets written on the
page how much of that
is just how it has to be planned out
once
the shooting is going on we know we have
to write just just for the
for the crew we have to always write it
so so i would write i wrote a sequence
in el paso
and i sit with every otto when he came
on he's like oh let's do this i had a
tank in there
and he always wanted to do a warner i
don't know if you noticed that the first
i think minute and a half is a winner
so that changed a lot that was like well
how do we do what i wrote
in a one or now with a tank
and then a lot of stuff gets cut when
you're doing a one like i had these
crazy rollerblading purgers there
and they got cut out of the movie and so
yeah it's constantly evolving but we're
constantly we have to write it just for
pre-production and production
and then um we're always filtering it
through
my eyes and everardo said he's got to
see it you know that's always the thing
like he's got to be able to envision it
because he's the guy on set
putting on its feet but once he came up
with the idea for a warner that made it
very complicated
so we had helicopters tanks all going
through this one you know we were on the
universal watch shooting that which was
a privilege to do
and uh yeah it's it was that was a tough
sequence that was the toughest one in
the whole movie
yeah it seems like so many things could
go wrong it's exactly points along the
way
yeah and they did and the actors have to
be very patient because
like you said there's so many moving
parts and if one person flubs a line
they restart the whole one or it's fair
i can't imagine how they make a movie
like birdman or you know these uh
these intense 10-minute sequences must
be so tense because if one person screws
up
you're back to one it's got to be very
hard yeah and you don't want to be that
guy though you don't want to be that
person exactly
yeah i just worked with naomi watch she
said no one wanted to be the person
who screwed up their line like minute
seven of a ten minute sequence
you know so uh yeah it's a lot a lot of
nerves on set
well thank you so much for talking to me
about all things purge i appreciate yes
christina thank you thank you thank you
for watching the tv show that makes me
very happy so
yeah i love the show another journalist
friend of mine and i both watched it
and we talk about our love for it all
the time oh it's great honestly i'm
going to call my showrunner friends and
tell them that that's great thank you
thank you so much have a great day